[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  Mondays am i right Joe you don't have a  good day have a great day hey bud you  ever think that there's got to be more  more than what stuff we do it day after  day being shot at run over taken hostage  today's gonna be different  hi this is it you you don't do this man  he's just resting is dead Wow  [Music]  this what recreational drugs feel like  guy this world it's a video game  and it's full of bad guys I'm a rule  breaker I'm a rheticus maker we need you  to be the good guy  giddyup  is that a Glock in your pocket know what  it's two clocks  [Music]  I'm not gonna be the good guy I'm gonna  be the great guy okay  well enjoy your lifetime supply of  virginity  [Music]